do you ever feel like you were more
focused on music and other like was
music ever did you ever make being an
artist a priority over being an nba
footballer sure when you're in the
studio i got 500 songs
that's a lot
you know what i'm saying
wow
and then like i would say
300 of them or maybe 204
not finished
so but i got 100 of them that i was in
the studio fit 16 hours because you know
it takes like yeah about 14 16 hours if
because you
as far as just putting out music
i put out three albums my last season my
career now you put out a lot of nobody
know about it i took it off and then a
lot what's funny is like um
we always think of like
nba players who have tried to do the
label thing like kd for a while had an
artist he was working with melo cassidy
was signed to carmelo anthony for a
little bit uh amari stoddameyer had a
label i love music sports hip-hop and
basketball are so synonymous with each
other but i do feel like as an artist
you probably had one of the more like
active runs like i was very active some
people would i'm surpr like some people
will kind of discredit that but i was
active
for a long time but nobody worked and
you were putting out music with like a
lot of
legends i was put on music a lot of
people but one of the things i wish it
was a couple things i wish i did with
music
like when i retired i was going to do
one of four things
full-time music
and i actually thought about this
full-time music i studied for my series
seven
so i was studying for my series seven um
management what i'm doing now or
or all the marketing and then as i was
going through it the pros and cons of
music was being up late being in the
because i was gonna do it i wouldn't
give 110 yeah so i chose to go back to
ucla and went back to school i went back
to concordia irvine but when i was
putting out music [ __ ] i was
i mean i got a champion sold 150 000.
that's crazy you know that was my most
successful record and um i mean i was
engineering most artists nowadays can't
sell 150 000 units
just to be honest i mean it's a
different different time
different circumstances but 150 000
units is a big win for a lot of artists
i appreciate that one i wish i i think i
should have i would have bet if i would
have writer now i look back at it i
would i would i would wish i would have
a writer
or a r
because i was doing records with
everybody
i mean i was in position to win yeah but
i don't think i um the operational side
of music and it's a hard mountain to get
over to be taken serious
when people think of you as a
all-time great basketball player that's
true by being from queensbridge and my
whole story no you had a crazy story you
had the street cred you had all that but
i just mean in terms of like it's hard
for people to like look at it at someone
i think damien uh has done a good job he
does a good job he's doing a good job uh
obviously back in the day shaq had some
platinum records obviously um shaq for a
while jack damien iman i like i like
album as though iman came in freestyle
then [ __ ] caught a body you know he's
incredible i'm not a freestyler i'm more
like emotional you know
so i like when i get into the booth i'm
just thinking about something that
happened and then you want something you
write it down and that's it it's more
like but when i'm on stage i'm like
fully in um
on stage i think like you know i'm fully
in cheat up mode on stage like i'm ready